[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs un numéro un peu
particulier ce soir nous parlerons
essentiellement du téléthon de
nombreuses animations sont prévues les 6
et 7 décembre prochain pour récolter un
maximum de dons pour la recherche
le sommaire baptêmes de plongée
découverte de la nage avec palmes défi
pour les apnéistes le club de plongée de
saint quentin en yvelines vous attend à
la piscine salvador allende téké souvent
le téléthon revient aussi à coignières
des jeux des activités sportives et des
sensibilisation au handicap vous seront
proposés et l'agenda complet de vos
sorties au programme d'autres
rendez-vous du téléthon du cinéma est un
spectacle et le téléthon c'est avant
tout une question de solidarité mais
c'est aussi l'occasion de relever des
défis
le club de plongée de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en lançant aux
pratiquants d'apnée mais propose aussi
une découverte de leur activité
rencontre
le monde du silence jusque dans une
piscine un calme apparent qui demande un
peu de travail de concentration
rendu célèbre en 1988 avec le film de
luc besson
l'apnée est pratiqué par le club de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'apnée c'est prendre conscience qu'on
est que l'être humain est capable de
faire des choses que le mental pense
qu'il peut pas faire on apprend une
respiration spéciale pour les apnéistes
que pratiquent tous les apnéistes et on
apprend surtout à se détendre
le maître mot pour le téléthon les
analystes se lanceront un challenge
réaliser un maximum de longueur de 25
mètres pendant six heures à la piscine
salvador allende des clayes-sous-bois
pour l'apnée c'est un petit peu
particulier parce que les gens qui vont
participer doivent avoir un minimum de
niveau apnée on peut pas se permettre
pour des raisons de sécurité de faire
venir n'importe quelle personne diarra
également
de la plongée donc il va y avoir des
baptêmes organisé également de la nage
l'âge classique en surface donc le défi
est lancé pour le samedi 7 décembre dès
14 heures les dons seront reversés à
l'afm téléthon pas de défi sportif cette
fois mais de nombreuses animations à
coignières aussi on s'investit cette
année pour le téléthon et les
organisateurs sont avec nous en plateau
les organisatrices ce soir on s'arrache
les trois cas déjà bien isabelle
montagne et christine de l'ami on se
lance donc une nouvelle fois dans
aventure haguenau à coignières mais oui
on a dit que ce serait bien de faire
tous les ans maintenant qu'on a marqué
au fer le veut la première année il va
falloir essayer de continuer c'est
toujours aussi important de se lancer
dans la recherche pour aider la
recherche pendant que dire oui bien sûr
bien sûr et on a la chance d'être aidés
pour se faire par de nombreux bénévoles
et donateurs des partenaires et ça nous
booste évidemment pour refaire cette
deuxième édition
mais isabelle monter sans les bénévoles
ont aidé et on ne fait rien ne fait rien
non non c'est vrai qu'on a une trentaine
de bénévoles qui nous entourent qui nous
qui nous qui nous soutiennent qui nous
mobilisent qu'ils nous demandent quand
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire auprès de vous vraiment ils
nous attendent et ils vont nous entourer
de façon tout à fait gay et
ça nous va sano positive une positive
attitude
ça faisait ne booste ça se passe au
gymnase du moulin à vent à coignières
est ce que la ville est là avec vous
aussi oui vous ont apporté
c'est vrai que la mairie de coignières
nous soutient énormément cette année on
a des êtres des services techniques on a
les êtres du service communication
on est très très encadré très c'est un
gros soutien et puis et puis du coup
mais c'est vrai qu'on travaille beaucoup
en lien avec eux et on travaillait
maintenant par rapport à la
communication aussi
donc voilà on est très soutenue par
christine la mit alors en alsace et tout
ce qui s'est passé avant pour construire
tout ça mais sur la journée ça va être
remplie il y à du sport il ya des
sensibilisations
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir découvrir
majid vous déclinez tout en un avec mon
petit antisèches parce que c'est vrai
qu'on voulait faire simple au début et
autre chose et au final on voit la
caisse qui suit donc on a pour le tout
ce qui va être fort on a du ping pong
on a du badminton on a
de la danse avec une initiation au
country est certainement nos petits pas
de danse on ne sait pas encore lequel on
va avoir une soirée country rock donc là
aussi c'est du sport m'a dit et ça ça se
fera ça se fera dans l'after votre café
donc un café qui participe pas ça aussi
avec nous à coignières on aura d'autres
jeux donc des jeux de société en bois on
a une sensibilisation au handicap à
travers divers ateliers comme d'être
assis dans un fauteuil roulant et une de
faire des parcours avec une porte et
c'est comme ça on se rend compte de ce
que vivent tous les jours des personnes
concernées tout à fait un tout un tas
d'autres handicaps aussi qui va être
vraiment petit jeu où elle est de
découvrir sans cela c'est la
sensibilisation qui va se passer donc le
7 décembre mais vous commencez à vent en
fait les animateurs que les
organisateurs vous allez voir les élèves
oui lundi prochain nous allons nous
avons la chance d'être accueillis dans
une classe de ce1
j'irai accompagné de monsieur legrand
qui est un papa qui est un enfant
porteur de myopathie et qui tenait
effectivement à s'investir aussi dans
cette dans cette manifestation
donc voilà on a eu cette belle surprise
d'être d'être attendu pour des enfants
de 8 ans oui donc parce que la
sensibilisation auprès des enfants c'est
très important autant qu'ils sachent de
quoi on parle quand on parle du téléthon
de quoi on parle quand on parle de
maladies génétiques
donc on est ravi d'être d'être
accueillis à l'école bouvet de
coignières justement la génétique c'est
le mot pour comprendre le téléthon et on
va le découvrir d'une manière un peu
ludique aussi chevaux avec des lego et
effectivement il y aura un atelier qu'il
y aura à peu près deux heures et qui
permettra aux gens de comprendre comment
la génétique exister comment est ce
qu'on soit comment elle se déshabille et
voilà c'est ça pourquoi on en arrive
parfois avoir des anomalies alors que
tout normalement devrait bien implique
un briquet ça se déplace à ce mois une
qu'à travers ces ateliers là les gens
pour nous on comprendre enfants comme
adultes dont on parle beaucoup du fait
de son nom d'hôpital heures mais chez
vous savez pas cette note là on m'aimait
couvert le dimanche
oui le dimanche le dimanche on a le
plaisir de de proposer un concert de 18h
à 20h qui démarrera par des jeunes
pianistes
dans la chef de choeur et irina giraudet
ensuite une chorale qui s'appelle nuance
gospel qui sera menée par valérie bono
et enfin un ensemble de cuivres qui est
menée par jean loup milhorat et tout ce
concert-là été organisée par maxime
peloton qui est lui aussi musicien et
qui est porteur de myopathie on reste
dans l'idée de jeter détourne la
sensibilisation j'imagine que l'objectif
cette année se battre le montant de
l'année dernière mais surtout de
sensibiliser
oui de toute façon quoi qu'il arrive
mais faire comprendre aux gens que
handicap il existe qu'il a qu'il est là
et que vient que en les aidants et les
chercheurs et les handicapés que l'on
peut réussir à mieux vivre tous ensemble
et à combattre la maladie coûte que
coûte
merci tout les trades est revenu on peut
doubler je voulais juste rajouté qu'il y
aura un food truck le midi et que nous
serions ravis d'avoir des dons
alimentaires cette fois ci
on a quelques quelques aliments
effectivement mais on n'est pas encore
au bout de notre liste donc n'hésitez
pas à nous contacter c'est
essentiellement pour du hamburger
oui oui c'est pour le midi donc voilà
non restauration rapide sur place
on a besoin d'aliments et on voulait et
je voulais excuses il a un peu pris par
le temps en quelques secondes juste
voilà il ya julien coll n'a pas pu se
joindre à nous il a une vocation et
voilà et donc il est très déçu de ne pas
être là ce soir également merci vraiment
à tous les bénévoles et à tous les
donateurs
merci à tous les donateurs on va le
rappeler parce que pour donner au
téléthon peut se déplacer sur les
animations mais on peut aussi le faire
en ligne le site va s'afficher en bas de
l'écran ou le par téléphone au numéro
que maintenant on connaît tous le 36.37
on continue à parler du téléthon tout le
monde se mobilise même les plus jeunes
associations adema une école de musique
et de théâtre intercommunal sur
auffargis et essar le mans et le père
est enlevé et les élèves d'une classe
des bréviaires propose un spectacle un
projet autour de deux histoires bien
connu de tous le livre de la jungle et
pierre et le loup
la particularité de ce spectacle sur
scène des marionnettes pour s'est créé
par les enfants
on a commencé en fait tout tout début
octobre
et donc on fait une séance de travail
par semaine c'est eux qui ont pensé les
marionnettes qui ont tant qu'ils ont
fait les décors qui ont réalisé une
partie des marionnettes
ils ont pleins d'imagination c'est
fantastique
ils sont très très moteur et un petit
panorama sur tout ce qui se passe sur
les autres communes de saint quentin en
yvelines alors à magny les hameaux vous
êtes attendus le vendredi 6 dès 19h vous
pourrez vous exercer au basket à la
gymnastique et à la danse le thème de
cette année gourmandise et bonbonnière
jouer dans ces marchés à guyancourt les
animations débutent le vendredi 6
décembre dès 13h30 avec une marche
proposée par guyancourt accueille un bon
moyen de se mettre en jambes avec lui
avant le loto et la soirée country à vi
procède au gymnase alain mimoun à
l'école duclos crozatier que ça se passe
vous pourrez notamment faire des
baptêmes de supercars ou assister à des
concerts
le téléthon est aussi très sportif du
côté de montigny le bretonneux des
challenges des ateliers
lancers francs de la marche nocturne 30
heures à vivre au centre sportif pierre
de coubertin aux clayes-sous-bois
direction l'espace sportif thierry les
gilardi où les majorettes de saint cyr
lanceront les animations de vendredi des
démonstrations des lotos et un bal sont
au programme
les bénévoles mort pas bien vous atteint
217 dessin à partir de 10h pour des
stages des ateliers des démonstrations
douze associations et clubs sont
rassemblés au gymnase de la malle me
donne et dans la dernière commune
voisins le bretonneux les 30 heures
seront axés autour d'un fil rouge un
voyage dans le temps l'association les
belles villes chinoises partage sa
passion pour les voitures de collection
un dernier rendez-vous à propos du
téléthon il a lieu ce week-end à bois
d'arcy et se passe en musique d'hommes
et pascal donnais vous font découvrir
toutes les facettes de charles aznavour
les deux artistes interprètent plusieurs
titres du chanteur disparu l'an dernier
ils se produisent sur la scène de la bri
blues les profits de la soirée seront
reversés à l'afm téléthon extraits ils
sont venus ils sont tous là qu'ils ont
entendu
elle va mourir là
ils sont venus ils sont tous là même
ceux du sud de l'italie
y'a même pior sur le fils maudit
avec des présents les bras tous les
enfants jouent au silence autour de
livres sur les carreaux urgent nouvelle
importance c'est un peu leur dernier
tour la main
voilà ma
ah on part maintenant aux
clayes-sous-bois pour parler de cinéma
hugo basquin de l'espace philippe noiret
vous donne quelques films à découvrir on
écoute cette semaine dans l'espace
philippe noiret des clayes-sous-bois
nous avons le temps attendue libérée
délivré et oui vous l'aurez reconnu la
reine des neiges 2 est programmé pour au
moins deux semaines à l'espace philippe
noiret l'intrigué du film tourne autour
de ce questionnement pourquoi elsa est
elle née avec des pouvoirs magiques se
rêvait de le découvrir avec l'aide de
ses amis anna christophe olha fait
semaine nous vous donnons également
rendez vous pour notre événement cinéma
jeudi 28 novembre à 14 heures ce sera si
n'était ou café en vous faisant
redécouvrir le film lulu femme nue et de
solveig anspach avec karin viard
vous la retrouverez également dans le
film chansons douces programmé à
l'espace philippe noiret la semaine
prochaine cette semaine nous avons
également le film à couteaux tirés de
ryan johnson un drame policier riche en
couleurs surmonté de touche d'humour
vous transportera dans un univers
semblable au célèbre jeu de société
super credo harlan trombert en place le
docteur lenoir ce célèbre auteur de
polar est retrouvé mort dans sa
somptueuse propriété
le soir de ses 85 ans c'est le détective
benoît blanc a interprété par le
charismatique daniel craig qui est alors
engagée par un commanditaire anonyme
afin d'élucider la faire mais entre la
famille d'alan qui s'entredéchirent et
son personnel qui lui reste dévoué blanc
plonge dans les méandres d'une enquête
mouvementée mais leurs mensonges et
fausses pistes où les rebondissements
s'enchaînent à un rythme effréné
jusqu'à la toute dernière minute une
oeuvre qui sera vous plaire c'est
pourquoi nous vous invitons à venir la
voir à l'espace philippe le ray dès que
les sous bois
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce site loisirs merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve jeudi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]